Yannick Jado est le meilleur candidat pour l'écologie.
L'écologie est 1 conservatisme.
La nupece est 1 idée judicieuse.
Ah, ça dépend,
c'est pas toujours le cas.
Écologie et agriculture ne font pas bon ménage. Faux. Non,
il existe 1 écologie de droite.
Non. La cop 28 est 1 réussite. Non.
Il faut envoyer des soldats français en Ukraine.
Non. Les agriculteurs ont raison de se révolter.
Oui, j'étais présent aux manifestations des agriculteurs.
Oui, Jordan Bardella
est le candidat le plus apprécié par les agriculteurs.
Non, je pense pas.
Les méga bassines aident les agriculteurs.
Faux. Non, l'Union européenne appauvrit les agriculteurs.
J'suis obligé de dire oui comme c'est aujourd'hui. Oui.
Darmanin a eu raison de
tenter de dissoudre les soulèvements de la terre.
Non, il y a trop de réglementations sur l'agriculture.
Non, c'est pas le sujet.
Il faut construire de nouvelles éoliennes en Europe.
Oui, la crise climatique se réglera par l'innovation
technologique.
La France insoumise propose 1 bon
programme sur l'écologie.
Oui, il faut 1
gouvernement mondial
pour régler le problème de l'écologie, non ?